free legal advice on the internet is
shall we say
bad and unfortunately some of the worst
takes come from one of my favorite
places on the internet reddit's r
slash legal advice and of course on the
other hand anyone with an internet
connection knows the best headlines
always begin with
floor demand so what happens when you
combine the subreddit legal advice
and florida well it gets interesting
[Music]
and today's episode of bad legal advice
comes from reddit user clean
transportation who shares her own
floor-to-man story she writes
regular customer tipped me scratch
tickets for years i finally won
something and
they're threatening legal action because
i don't want to give them a cut
florida of course i worked as head
bartender for a local restaurant for a
number of years and there was a regular
customer who was there very frequently
i interacted with this customer
frequently they tipped exclusively in
scratch tickets and
specifically called to ask for my
schedule asked me out on multiple
occasions etc
probably about 40 years my senior if
you've ever watched the good place this
guy is irl brent
it's all about taking personal
responsibility not enough people do that
now okay so this isn't exactly legal
advice but just
general life advice please don't ask out
your bartenders who are just
working don't mistake their professional
courtesy for genuine
interest and if a person has already
said they aren't interested in the first
time
they typically aren't charmed if you ask
them repeatedly i
hate to be the one to tell you this but
80s movies kind of lied to you
persistence in the face of no
isn't romantic in this day and age it's
creepy so come on let's just
not do that but i digress back to the
post
i won something from the scratch ticket
that wasn't five ten dollars the final
amount after taxes was about three
months salary for me and i was making
good money
i specifically didn't tell the customer
not because i thought they would want it
but
because i didn't want them feeling like
i owed them something or that i should
be thankful towards them i did tell a
co-worker and it got to him through the
grapevine
next time i came in he congratulated me
and asked me how he wanted to split it
i sternly told him that it was my tip
and long story short
he went to my manager who took his side
i quit had been planning to anyway since
i'm about to finish school
my manager gave this guy my email i'm
curious about the legality of this too
and he the customer emailed me saying
that if i didn't agree to give him 50
he'd take legal action so here we have a
female employee dealing with a bar
patron who has repeatedly declared a
romantic interest in her which
is not reciprocal threatens a lawsuit
over a tipped ticket and after
all of that the manager gives the bar
patron her email address
this is what we call in the legal
profession a
total move it's also the same in bird
culture but
this probably isn't illegal i know this
isn't the main part of the story but
she's asking for legal advice here and i
just have to sink my teeth into this one
so aside from information classified as
confidential like an employee's medical
history
the disclosure of most employee personal
information to third parties is largely
unregulated many employers regularly
share their employees personal
information with
third-party vendors to run background
checks to outsource administrative
functions and so on
in florida which does have a right to
privacy written into its state
constitution
does not have any specific laws that
would prevent an employer from providing
an employee's personal information
and florida laws against invasion of
privacy like intrusion or publication of
private facts
typically require showing that the
disclosure of such information is
offensive or
goes beyond all possible bounds of
decency so it's not clear that the
manager giving out an employee's email
to a patron even one threatening to sue
her
meets the offensiveness standard and
finally another standard caveat when i
do these things this could totally be
fake i don't
know this could be completely made up i
don't really care this is fun to talk
about it's an interesting legal issue
but anyway
back to the putative reddit post do i
need to worry about taking his threat
seriously
is there anything that i can or should
do to protect myself
i'm assuming this is a bluff but i want
to have my bases covered
tldr me drink lady mean man who buy many
drinks give me a scratchy scratching
okay we get it
so she is worried that this guy is going
to sue her
for some or all of the lottery winnings
and
this can be a complicated issue
believe me anytime the lottery is
involved lawyers are not far behind
there is a long history of lottery law
out there but before we dive into this
complicated legal mess let's check in
with the comments to see if
any of these redditors offered some good
legal advice
and in fact x shady writes like green
paper um buy dizzy drink with green
paper unhappy
yeah so that's pretty much about the
quality of legal advice that you're
likely to get when you ask for free
advice
on the internet it's basically random
postings from the unfrozen caveman
lawyer your world
frightens and confuses me and that might
be reason enough alone
for this redditor to retain council
because in america of course
you can sue anyone at any time over just
about anything
and even if a lawsuit is completely
meritless you still have to defend the
case
but here since the unfrozen caveman
lawyer is unavailable
r.i.p phil hartman this redditor could
hire a lottery lawyer yes that's right
there actually is
a thing called lottery law a lottery
lawyer can help navigate tax laws
keep your identity anonymous when you
claim your prize and defend you from
potential lawsuits over the winnings
like
this potential lawsuit because winning
the lottery can turn into a messy battle
that
ruins friendships tears apart families
and explodes into
costly lawsuits and this is especially
the case where you have
the dreaded workplace lottery pools for
example in 2012
12 co-workers in illinois won 118
million dollars and they were sued by
11 of their other colleagues who claimed
that they were in the pool and demanded
a share it took three years and six law
firms to settle the case with
the original 12 getting six million
dollars each and six others splitting
13.8 million dollars but
no one got a penny of that until the
case was resolved and similarly in 2009
five construction workers in a lottery
pool
sued when the sixth co-worker took a
38.5 million dollar jackpot
quit his job and then disappeared a
judge ordered the defendant to surrender
20 million dollars to the five former
co-workers
that's why lottery lawyers recommend all
workplace lottery pools have a sharing
agreement in writing
because just like biggie says mo
financial remuneration
mode judicial proceedings and legal
ramifications but let's dive back into
the comments maybe there's something
else that's better in here for example
signup accounts writes if you get sued
then you'll need to show up and comply
with any judge's orders
fair enough but right now you owe him
nothing and don't even have a
responsibility to reply to his emails do
save them just in case you get sued
though
but if he is threatening litigation i
would recommend ceasing all contact from
this point forward without an attorney
present
and this is technically correct you
are technically correct the best kind of
correct
typically you have no legal obligation
to respond to pre-litigation demand
letters threatening a lawsuit and if the
bar patron hasn't even retained a lawyer
this could just be an empty threat
and then another redditor meowzebub
chimes in helpfully and just to clarify
why this is important
if this guy files a lawsuit against the
redditor which he is completely entitled
to do regardless of the lack of legal
basis for the claim
she needs to show up or be ruled against
by default
and these comments are interesting
because they're not really getting to
the heart of the substantive issue but
they're really interested in civil
procedure and you know they're not wrong
and it's important to note that a
plaintiff isn't entitled to file a
meritless
lawsuit if a plaintiff files a lawsuit
that they know has no legal basis
whatsoever
they can be subject to sanctions but as
we see time and time again
people will often file these meritless
suits and avoid sanctions because
it's rare for judges to take that extra
step and it's hard to weed out
the lawsuits that have merit from the
ones that are completely meritless at
the first stages but
meowzib who has a hilarious username
does make a very important point
even if the case is complete nonsense
you still have to defend yourself from
the lawsuit
otherwise you could lose automatically
by default i guess you're the winner by
default
default when a person is sued
and served with an official court
summons and a complaint the defendant
only has a limited amount of time to
file a response either what's called a
motion to dismiss or a formal answer to
the complaint
if a defendant fails to file any
response or otherwise abandons the case
the plaintiff can request the court
enter what's called the default judgment
against the absence he defendant so
that's why it's so incredibly important
to be actually represented by council if
you are formally sued but back to the
crux of this reddit post the central
question is whether there is an
enforceable contract between the bar
patron
and the bartender to split the ticket
winnings and this is really important
because most people assume that a
contract has to be written but that's
actually not the case only a small
number of contracts must be
in writing and in fact sometimes there
can even be an implied
contract based on the actions of the
individuals
so it's not nearly as cut and dry as it
would appear in fact generally speaking
a contract doesn't have to be in writing
to be enforceable as both
written contracts and oral contracts can
be valid
in fact most lottery lawsuits are based
exclusively on oral agreements to
share winnings because people don't
often write down their contracts and you
know that keeps lawyers
employed but all enforceable contracts
must have an offer an acceptance of that
offer and consideration
an offer is usually a specific proposal
to enter into an agreement with another
acceptance of that offer is an ascent to
the bargain which can either be
expressed like
signing an agreement or implied by
conduct and consideration is performance
or a return promise for which the party
to the contract has bargained
in order to constitute a bargain for
consideration both sides must negotiate
some benefit and or
detriment from one another in exchange
for the promises to perform
however a gift promise like a tip lacks
these required elements when you promise
someone a gift
there's no formal offer there's no offer
to accept and there's no consideration
a gift promise is not an invitation to
bargain because
the promissor is offering something
without demanding anything
in return since no exchange is sought by
the promising party there's no
consideration so for example
a court would not enforce a bear promise
to a friend that if the promiser ever
won the lottery
then the lottery winnings would be
shared equally between the friends
thus a gift promise doesn't create an
enforceable contract
and this was essentially the conclusion
of a lawsuit against
tonda dickerson an alabama waffle house
waitress
who received a florida lottery ticket as
a tip that won
10 million dollars two years after
winning edward seaward the
man who left the lottery ticket as a tip
sued dickerson and her co-workers to
recover the entire 10 million dollar
prize
in his complaint seward alleged
dickerson had promised to buy him a
truck with any
lottery winnings she didn't do that and
thus seward was
claiming to be a victim of fraudulent
misrepresentation
but instead of seeking to recover just
the truck sewer demanded that the court
invalidate the tip on the grounds of
fraud
and award him the entire 10 million
dollar lottery winnings
the trial court ruled against seward
holding that the tipped ticket was an
unconditional gift
and found no evidence of fraud and in
support of their ruling the court found
that dickerson had made no
misrepresentations to seward before she
received the lottery ticket
seward gave dickerson the ticket without
previously discussing what would happen
if she won
not on this occasion nor on any previous
occasion of tipping the waffle house
employees with lottery tickets
and dickerson never requested a lottery
ticket from seward rather he just
gave it to her freely and without
expectation and of course
sewer did not limit his damages to the
claim that he was entitled to a new
truck but was
claiming the entire 10 million dollar
prize which you know
probably didn't help his case all that
much seward appealed his case to the
alabama supreme court
and lost so this reddit case seems to be
pretty similar to the seward case both
seward and the reddit bar patron had a
pattern of leaving lottery tickets as
tips for servers
there's no indication that either patron
discussed sharing the proceeds from
winning tickets with their servers
and there's no indication that the
servers fraudulently misrepresented that
they would share the winnings to induce
the
patrons to leave the lottery tickets as
a tip
so based on these facts it doesn't seem
like the bar patron has any right to
share in
the redditor's winnings now maybe the
redditor is holding back
if there was a discussion if there was
an oral contract that could change the
facts of this case
by the way this is what lawyers do all
the time we analogize to old cases and
we analyze them
in comparison to the cases before us so
whether it's reddit or whether it is an
actual lawsuit this is the kind of stuff
that we do every day and
there are certainly facts that this
redditor might have left out from the
post that could change this outcome but
based on what we know i'm sorry to the
bar patron but you are not entitled to
anything
from the lottery winnings but one way to
feel like you've won the lottery is to
get the perfect domain name for your
website and when i need a new domain i
go with today's sponsor hover
maybe i should buy up a specialty
website like lotterylawyer.com and
specialize in representing all the
people who
think that they're owed money from
someone else's lottery win
huge retainer required obviously hover
is the best place on the internet to get
yourself a domain name in part because
they have over 400 extensions to choose
from ranging from dot com
dot io dot me to dot ninja and dot pizza
seriously you can even get democrat or
dot republican for your website i use
hover whenever i need a domain for
example i got legaleagle.tv
and legaleagleprep.com for the website
that helps law students
i highly recommend that everyone go get
their name dot com or the name of their
business.com
or dot io or dot whatever before it's
gone and with hover it is super easy to
get a domain there are no upsells
no annoying pop-ups and if you have an
account like i do you can get another
domain
in less than 30 seconds or just check to
see if that website is still available
and once you've got your domain hover
makes it incredibly easy to set up a
professional email address
even if you don't want to set up a
website you can still get professional
email because you never want to be that
person that uses a
aol or earthlink email address in 2021
don't be steven biss of course the best
part is that if you go over to hover.com
legal eagle which you can find in the
description below you'll get 10
off your entire order again just go to
hover.com
legaleagle or click on the link in the
description to get 10
off of your entire order plus clicking
on the link really helps out this
channel so do you agree with my analysis
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
where i tackle
all the things that people get wrong
about the law on the internet including
and
especially on reddit so click on this
playlist or i'll see you
in court